if I need to arm myself you know the
easiest thing to manufacture in most
places is a pointed object so I can take
that Crystal big pen that you're writing
on that uh notepad with and using the
friction from the carpet I can turn it
into a hypodermic needle that you can
then poke into somebody's neck what's
the process of doing that I can do it
right now if you want no but can you can
you use your words for The Listener and
also because I'm terrified no I could I
could basically you can take the
friction the the Heat and friction
created from this carpet yes you can
grab that pen in and of itself it will
pierce flesh but it will slow itself
down because it has a few uh angles on
to on the tip oh you want to wear down
the angles so if you take that tip off
and you grab it and grind it on an angle
on the carpet the heat will actually
turn it into a hypodermic needle if you
know what you're doing hypodermic
meaning like it's it smoothens the entry
it'll make a point and an angle that
will guide its way into your flesh so
you can actually go through a torso with
that if you know what you're doing
as a small tangent you also gave me a
present
could be one of the most epic presents
I've ever received you you give it to
Rogan uh can you explain what I'm
holding in my hands there's a guy online
coffin [ __ ] this is a moniker uh it is
a
G10 Rod G10 is a very strong material
basically capable a lot of people make
actually G10 knives which are basically
non-magnetic non-ferrous objects that
can be utilized as a stabbing implement
uh the core of it isn't uh isn't an
actual pencil core it's a G10 core and
it's uh encased in uh Oak hard Oak
so that is capable again of stabbing
through a torso now the guy that made
that uh is an Hardison you know it makes
that it looks like a pencil it's
concealed in in the nature of the object
itself
but that's one object is capable of
being introduced into a chest cavity
um you know all it takes is about the
half of your thumb or the length of your
thumb to stab into your chest cavity and
now your pericardium is pierced then
it's being full with filled with blood
or your whole heart is pierced then you
have a few minutes to live if you're at
a standing heart rate so this is uh this
this says the effectiveness of a knife
essentially it has an effectiveness of a
shank or or or an ice pick you know it's
not going to cut but it's going to make
a whole word not the shouldn't be
here the the pen is literally mightier
than the sword yeah well it's uh
this is really epic from like a
perspective of an academic
this is this is a symbol of both
intelligence and violence I love it and
also the the current state of affairs
where people need to arm themselves with
things that are concealed as far as
their purpose in a place where in a
country or in a society that limits
their ability to arm themselves
so if you're going to a safe place
you're going to a place where no weapons
allowed which means a rich a Target Rich
environment if you're a predator
uh that's a sign of rebellion let this
be a signal of everyone should be
terrified when you're around me because
even a pencil can murder you and I
intend to use this and nobody nobody
owns life but anybody that can hold a
frying pan owns death is a quote that I
heard once which is a beautiful one I'm
looking at you if anyone betrays me this
is the way to go